で またもし時間があれば
もうちょっとちょっともうわかりやすいと専門的な説明やります
で これはもうすぐ慌てて作ったんですから
まだ日本語化になってないんです
で How does the river function? という輪廻はどのように起こるんでしょうか
と この起こり 輪廻のあり方
エクスプレッションのサイコロジカルプロセスということで
で これから英語で書くとすごく早いんですよ
で この心の流れをこれから説明します
はい 次に行きます で トラックピースのコンシャスネスという
まあなんとかわかるでしょう
コンシャスネスっていうのは意識
心ですね トラックというのはトラックですね
あの小さなトラックピース
音楽でよく使いますね
それが音楽なんか この録音する場合は
音楽 小さな部分 部分 部分
部分を取って取って取って取って取って取って
それ全部つなげて合成して普通の曲を合成するんです
そうやって心もトラックピースとして起こるんです
認識が Just like perception occurs in the form of track pieces
この体を見ても 我々の DNA あるでしょ？ DNA から小さなあの
ストリップ作れますよ
それを RNA というんですけど
だから体がそれで動いているんです
DNA は何もしない ただ隠れて邪魔って待ってるだけで
でもその時その時  RNA という小さな部品を作るんです
それが体中行って 髪の毛が白くなるわ
年取るわ もう反抗期になるわ
もういろんなことを人間やってるんです
だから本当に我々の命が RNA でできているんです
DNA は基本的にその時必要な RNA 作り出すだけ
結果出したら RNA が壊れます
DNA は基本プログラムで残っているんです
で これは物質の場合は心でも同じ働きが起こるんです
例えば視覚の場合 視覚っていうのは
目で何か見た場合は こういう
このまるまるまるまる書いてるのは心っていう意味なんです
心は瞬間瞬間で ここで心が生まれて消えて
別な心が生まれる 消えて別な心が生まれる
これが消えて また別な心が生まれる
そうやって心が現れては消える
現れては消える その過程で物を見るということをするんです
そこで 17 にしているのは
この物質と心のスピードなんです
物質は心の 17回生滅変化すると
物質は一回変化変わるんです
だから速度で言えば光の速度
物質の速度なんです 物質
光の速度になってくると
物質は物質でなくなるんです
元に戻るんです 物質 だからその速度でもう言うんですけど
無分身 まあちょっとこの背景で失敗しました
ね これ見えないね 背景今はちょっといかないんだから
背景ですことできます
これ無分身と書いてます
無分身っていうのはもうただこの何も考えない心なんです
次に目に情報触れたでしょ
無分身が動揺しちゃうんです
次の瞬間に揺れるんです
揺れ 揺れて 次の心で無分身が切断されます
無分身っていうのは何も認識しない
ただ無意識みたいな心
これが情報触れた瞬間に動揺しちゃって切れちゃう
切れて次の瞬間で五感
五感 何か間違えています
五感門を開く で 情報どこから来たのかと心がその五感に門を開くんです
五感 これ見る時の説明です
開いたところで 次の心で眼識っていうものが現れる
そこでデータ目から取るんです
それから心で次の心 この心が死んじゃうんですよ
いつでも私たちのあるのは心一つだけなんです
いつでも一つじゃないんです
これで眼識がなくなって受信が生まれるんです
情報が受け取ったこと
次のこの心がなくなる
なくなって適当に次の心が生まれる
種があると芽が生まれるって話で
受信が生まれたら次に必ずその分別心が生まれる
何を見たのかと分別し
何を生まれたっていうことを終わってから
次のステップは分別心なんです
分別する だから種があって
芽があって 葉っぱが出て
もう伸びてとか そんな順番に
判別心が終わっちゃうとそこはなくなる
なくなったところから行動心が生まれるのです
7つ 判別したところで
その行動心が終わったら
また物質は寿命があるんだから
その間でなんか化身と書きますけど
ちょっと心が落ち着いて
で また五蘊心に戻るのです
で これで全てじゃない
この中でも視覚の場合のこうやって
トラックピースはいくつかあるんです
結構大量にあります まあ大体子供の頃はそれを覚えて勉強しなきゃいけないんです
かなりたくさんあります
これで一応一応見たということになります
だから我々は目を閉じて目を開けた瞬間にこれを受けているんです
しかし 何を見たかまだわからないんです
それからこのデータがまた慰問に心に入って
心で考えたりする それから意識の場合はどうなるかと
心だけで考える場合は
まず五蘊心があって それからすぐ切れる
五蘊心が動揺する暇がないんです
心だけの話だから すぐ切れちゃって
慰問を開く 次の心 次の心で意識する
それから受信する 自分で自分のデータを受信する
それから分別して判別する
判別した瞬間でさっとある心が流れちゃうんです
エネルギーを吸っている心が
行動心が これは大体決まってて
7回です 決まって 7回心が起こるんです
この判別したところで
あ これはきれいというふうに判別したところで
さっと心が流れるんです
流れてエネルギーが消えて消える
だから流れるエネルギーは 7回で終わるんです
心はもうすごい計算してますけどね
それが化身という落ち着く心が 2つ起きます
起きてまた五蘊心に戻ります
いつでも五蘊心に戻る
そんな流れなんですね
心は そこで私はもう何とか言うでしょうね
もう今日は疲れましたとか言う場合は
もう数えられないほど多数のトラックピースまとめて疲れたというだけです
これらのトラックの繰り返しで
我々の見る 見たいという視覚的な知識が起こるのです
だから前説明したのは見える働き
今見たものは頭に入れる働き
それで見て頭に入れて
見て 頭に入れて 見て 見て
頭に入れて ああ あれは知ってるんだぞとか
偉そうなことを言うんです
でもすごい働きなんです
無数に心が現れてくる
それを一つ一つ仏教はショーと死で説明するのです
はい 聞く 味わうなどの五感の知識もこのようにトラックピーススで起こるのです
次に五感の情報を慰問に流して
意識 思考 判断などが起きているのです
だからもう意識に流しちゃうと
そこでチャップピース一つ
二つではなくて 何億も来ちゃうし
それで考えたり妄想したりする
このトラックピーススのつながりが普通に言っている心というものなのです
このトラックピーススは 1本にずっとつなげるんです
つなげて我々が言っている心っていうのはそんなもんなんです
我々心でいたっても大量のものなんですね
まあ大体はい それぐらいで次
そこでトラックピーススピースオブコンシャスネスアットタイムオブデス
死ぬ時はどんなものになるかと
この場合は ま レジの時の心の流れ
慰問で説明します これ仮にこれは目でも耳でも説明できます
最後の心のトラックピースが耳で起こるかもしれません
目で起こるかもしれません
鼻で起こるかもしれません
体で起こるかもしれません
あるいは胃だけで起こるかもしれません
最後の瞬間の心 死ぬ瞬間の
どこもどこでもいいんです
そこで慰問の場合は まず分身があって
次にこれ切れちゃう 切分する
切断する 次に慰問を開く
次に意識が現れる それは受信する
次の心で分別する 次の心で判別する
次の心で動く エネルギーで
でも最後だから心も弱いし
業のエネルギーもほとんど弱いし
もう死ぬ瞬間の瞬間だから流すつなげないんですよ
色情心が エネルギーは切れちゃう
そこで色情心は大体つか
8つかつかといろいろ決まりがあります
起きて死心という心が生まれるのです
最後の心 この死心も質的には分身なんです
無意識と同じなんです
質的には 死心が起きた瞬間で
同じ感覚で結晶心が生まれるんです
だから心の変遷 証明する流れはいつでも同じスピードなんです
そこで結晶心が生まれる
結晶心が生まれたら 次また確実に分身がスーッと流れる
エネルギーはない 何も考えない
情報もない だから無分心って無意識な心はかなり長い間続ける
だから思い出せないんですよ
もうこの間でも結構弱いんだから
だから指心までは今世
結晶心からは来世 目を開けて見る瞬間でも
1本のトラックが起こるでしょうし
死ぬ時でもまた一つのトラックでトラックでそれ起こるんです
これはもう転生の機能ですね
それはもうちょっとアドバンスというかね
仏教の心理学を知っている人だったら
まあ当たり前の話でどうったことはないんですけど
まあ一応それで話は終わりました
押してください また まあどうしてもあれ
理解できないという方々には
この最後の部分が理解すれば簡単ではないかなという思いです
というわけで レンネの話はここら辺で終了いたします
どうもありがとうございます
はい